Oh, we got
married from home.
Yeah, the wedding circuit. I got one.
That's it. None of my friends have uh
actually one of my extremely good
friends Ian who actually graduated from
Stern last year
this weekend.
Yeah. I'm I'm not a part of I have no
logistical responsibilities.
Yeah.
And you'll be the first my good friends.
You should have got your valuations back
if you sent them with the right subject.
If you did not, they're lost in 2,000
emails. So, send them again. So, it's
been I've I've had roughly 2,000 emails
in the last 10 days. So, I have no idea
where it's lost, right? I'm I should
have been clear on what I want titled my
perfect DCF. A lot of people title their
valuation spreadsheet my perfect DCF,
which really doesn't help much when I
screen. I just need the subject to be my
perfect ECF. So it went to the right
mailbox. But I think we got most I my
rough count was 357 DCFs. So no there
are about probably 50 people who never
turned in a DCF more than that. It's
closer to 400 DCFs by the time I was
done. So there I'm sure there are people
who did not turn in a DCF and if you
haven't and you still want feedback I
will give it to you.
So get it in. Don't wait till May 4th
please. No, that'll be a little close to
the end. So, do it as soon as you're
ready to turn it in. Right. So, today
I'm going to kind of hit two things
towards the very end. Last session, as
you remember, we could not get the
projector up. So, I was kind of, you
know, winging it based on what was in
the slides. But today, there are two
things towards the end of and I gave you
the video from the undergraduate class
because that did have the video and it's
pretty close to the same material. There
are two things I did to at the end of
the class that I'm going to start this
class off with as test. Now, one of my
favorite things to do at the start of
every year is to take the 100 largest
market cap stocks in the US and take
their price to book
ratios. What's a companion variable for
price to
book? You're a week away from the the
quiz.
So what's what's a trick we use in or an
equity multiple to get the companion
variable? You divide net income by the
denominator of your multiple, right? Net
income divide by book equity is return
equity. So price to book return equity.
And I did a scatter plot. Remember those
from statistics? Basically, you take
each company, you plot it out. There are
100 companies on this graph. And then I
seem to have drawn three random lines
through, but they're not quite
random. That this line that you see
there is the best fit line. It's just no
OS. It's a regression line. You know
what the two outer lines
are? And you run a regression and you
get predicted values. You also get
standard errors. Those are the 90th
percentile in terms. So everything that
falls within those two lines I cannot
statistically reject as being fairly
valued. So which should make sense right
100 large market cap stocks most should
fall within the line. But take a look at
the stocks that fall above the line and
the stocks that fall below the line.
First if I were just looking at price to
book return equity where are my
overvalued stocks? Above the line, below
the line, Mike above the line. So let's
go through some. There's Mastercard,
there's Apple, Eli
Liy, Palanteer, Crowd Strike, this Trade
Desk I think is TTV, Snowflake, and that
absolute basket case of a stock which is
Micro Strategy. I don't even know what
it is. There's two there were two people
in the undergraduate class who picked
Micro Strategy and they very quickly I
got them to change the company because
what's your what's your story for Micro
Strategy? Everybody familiar with
Michael Michael's strategy? Ever Bitcoin
play? It is a bit it's a Bitcoin play.
There's no business left anymore. It's
basically your bet on Michael Sailor
being able to predict where Bitcoin
price they're going to go, which is
makes it almost impossible as a it's a
trading device for
Bitcoin. So those are but they might be
overvalued. But what's the other
explanation you can give for why they
will fall above the line even if they're
not
overvalued? Remember the drivers of
price to book. Return equity is the
companion variable. But what else goes
into the mix? You have growth. Higher
growth company should have higher price
to
book. You have risk. Higher risk
companies should have lower price to
book. And in this case, what might
explain all those? What do those stocks
collectively above the line? What what
do they generally share in common? You
think what's the
one probably high growth stocks, right?
Is there a way I could bring growth into
this scatter
plot? Or have you seen a
three-dimensional scatter plot? It looks
like a box, right? Be price to book,
return, equity. It's kind of messy. But
what you're looking for again is that
combination. And you can already see why
we end up with regressions is you can
get dizzy looking at these things. And a
fourth dimension, forget about it. You
can't have four-dimensional scatter
plots. You'll have multiple scatter
plots across. So it's a very good
starting point where you can say hey
look what what's the only stock that
looks undervalued start of
Oracle interesting right a technology
company under the so and see Home Depot
that's at five I actually had to cap it
at five its price to book is now about
5,000 because it's its book value of
equity had become so small because of
the buybacks price to books are getting
more and more difficult to use as
buybacks drive book values of equity to
negative territory and beyond.
Oh, and it's a so it's gone back and
forth with this negative book value of
equity making it very difficult to even
think about book value market.
So that's the first. The second test I'm
going to run is actually
on a grocery
business and I'm going to take you back
to
2007 and grocery business are incredibly
boring this you know so usually the
analysts who work in this business are
used to companies with low margins and
low growth and they used to say multiple
EV to sales or everybody trades around
point and then in 2007 there's a new kid
in
town Whole Foods had just gone public
and analyst and knew didn't have any
idea what to do with it. It was a high
growth higher margin. I mean it's not
Ant Taylor type of margins but it's
margins much higher than they used to.
And they just threw up their hands and
said we have no idea what to do with
Whole Foods. See what
it's way above everybody else. But they
explained away it's higher growth. So in
2007 I actually put in Whole Foods
higher margins and said even with a
higher margin I can't explain where
whole food sits. If you get a chance
look at the next four graphs because I
track Whole Foods in 2009 2012 and as
you go through time what you'll see
Whole Foods doing is going from
overpriced to underpriced to finally
ending up right on the line. And there's
a broader message there. When a company
comes into a sector that's unusual and
analysts are not used to dealing with
that type of company, they'll mispric
it. Tesla when it first got listed,
tremendously mispriced, still mispriced,
but it's tremendously
mispriced, which is an opportunity if
you're an investor, right? The time to
pick these companies is when people have
no idea what to do with it because it's
so different from everybody else. Airbnb
in the hospitality business, right? At
least there you had booking and um
Expedia out there as comparisons. But
when you see a company where you can't
find comparisons right now, that might
frustrate you, but at the same time
means your intrinsic value carries more
weight. So I'm going to move forward to
page
79 and talk a little bit to about
companies. And this is especially direct
those of you doing negative earnings
companies trying to price your company.
Remember how your life was difficult
when you did intrinsic valuation, your
life will also be difficult when you do
pricing first. If you have a negative
earnings company already, you're getting
desperate, right? The only multiple you
can probably get to work is a revenue
multiple. So this is in 2000 when I
valued remember I showed you the
intrinsic valuation of Amazon that I did
where I overvalued found Amazon to be
tremendously overvalued. And in about
the same time I decide to price
Amazon.com company. So this is the
scatter plot of com companies of price
to sales. I mean I should have used
enterprise value to sales in hindsight.
Price to sales against net
margin. When you look at the scatter
plot what's your reaction? Trying to fit
a line through it is going to be a
nightmare. Right? Looks like a we talked
about shotgun blast. This is a shotgun
blast. There is no discernable
relationship between the two. And don't
be surprised if you see this with your
negative earnings company, especially if
it's a young company. You look at the
pure group, you pull up the numbers. No
real. So, I'm going to give you a couple
of things you can try that make sense.
Initially, here's what I did. I I
decided to run a regression anyway.
Price to sales against net margins on
that scatter plot. And the statistics
said there's no relationship. The R squ
is 0.0. 4. And the scarier thing was
look at the coefficient in the net
margin - 7.54. How would I read that?
What is that telling
me in this sector? The more money I
lose, the higher the multiple of
revenues I would rate it. Which if I'm
writing a book on irrational exuberance
would be exhibit one, right? Look at how
crazy people are. But you know what?
That's a dangerous place to be when you
start with the presumption people are
crazy and that's why they're doing this.
Let's face it, nobody was pricing Amazon
or any of the dot companies based on how
much money they made last year, right?
Let's play it out. Why were they buying
the companies? Because they expected
high growth in the future and that
eventually these companies would survive
and make money. So I decided to reframe
and this is the first thing you can do
is rather than running the traditional
regression price to book against return,
equity, growth, payout, you think about
why would people pay a high price to
book or a high price earnings. And here
I started with two
hypothesis. The first was higher revenue
growth companies should trade at higher
multiples of revenues than lower. So
because we lower growth company, I'd pay
a lower multiple. Second, I also assumed
that as your revenue scaled
up, your multiple would have to go down.
It's one thing to pay 500 times revenues
with the million dollar revenue company,
but those revenues become a billion and
10 billion. You're going to see a
scaling down. And there's a third and
final factor which reflects the fact
that these are all young companies. What
happens to most young companies? You
track them over time, they disappear.
Right? So there's got to be a survival
factor that people are factoring in. And
I'll throw out a hypothesis. When you
look at young companies failing, it's
almost never because they have debt.
It's because they run out of
cash. So here's the third variable I'm
going to bring in. The more cash these
companies have on their balance sheet,
the more likely they would survive. In
fact, at the peak peak of the dotcom
boom, analysts used to track how many
months of cash companies had on their
balance sheet. And if they had more
months of cash, they were given a higher
multiple. So here's what I did. I ran a
regression of price to sales ratios. And
this is desperation rearing its ugly
head. I said, "Look, nothing is working.
I want to try to explain why revenue
multiples are what they are." I took
price to sales. I threw in the level of
revenues, log of revenues. One of the
tricks you can use whenever you run
these multiple regressions, if you have
a variable where there are big
difference between the lowest and the
highest number, just take the natural
log. I know the statistics professor
would kill me for saying this because it
seems like a bludgeon approach. 95% of
the time in finance when you have a too
big of a variation in one of your
independent variables, throw the natural
log. It'll make them closer. So that's
basically what the log of revenues
captures. The revenue growth rate is
that because higher growth companies
should have higher price to sales and
the more cash these companies have the
higher so at least the coefficients are
all in the right direction plus 5.11
plus and the higher the revenues the
lower the price to sales ratio. If I
were running this regression I'd
probably take the log of revenues out of
the regression because the t statistic
is not significant but I'm going to
leave it in here because I already ran
the regression. So I put in Amazon's
numbers into this regression log of
Amazon's revenues, its revenue growth,
and how much cash it had. I got a
predicted price to sales ratio for
Amazon of
30.42. It was actually trading at 25.63
times. And that's a bit of a
contradiction, right? Because just
before I did this, I did the intrinsic
valuation and I concluded it was
significantly overvalued. Now I'm
running a pricing and concluding it's
significantly underpriced. How can both
be true at the same
time? What do you want to try? How can a
stock be both undervalued and overpriced
at the same time or over overvalued and
underpriced at the same time? France,
you want to try maybe?
Well, why isn't it a in both places? Why
is it a bubble in one in the intrinsic
valuation but not in the pricing?
Yes, the things you're comparing it to
are also conversely overvalued. In fact,
there are two separate questions I'm
asking right in intrinsic valuation.
What's the question I'm asking? How much
is this individual asset worth? Given
its cash flows, growth and risk, is this
stock under or overvalued? And we
conclude it's overvalued in this regress
in this pricing. What's the question?
I'm asking just
given how
other.com stocks are priced, is this
stock underpriced or overpriced? And
this is where the bubble argument comes
in. If you have a sector where
everything gets pushed up, you can have
something look cheap relative to the
sector but overvalued on an intrinsic
value basis. So some of you might find
this when you do the valuation, your
intrinsic valuation says your stock is
overvalued, but when you do the pricing,
it's going to come out as cheap. Don't
sit there pontificating about about deep
stuff. This isn't deep. You're asking
two separate questions. You got two
separate answers and you got to decide
what to do. If you're a trader, you'd go
with the pricing answer because you want
to make money off the pricing. If you're
an investor, you go the intrinsic value
answer. One is not better than the
other. They're just different
perspectives you bring to the
market. So, that's one strategy. So,
take your take your sector. There's
something you can use to explain the
differences. Here's the other. One of
the reasons you're having trouble
pricing your company is because you're
looking at today's numbers,
right? So, when you look at today's
numbers, those numbers are really small.
The company is small revenues, small
earnings. So, here's the other tactic
that analysts often use. Rather than
look at a multiple of revenues today or
a multiple of earnings today, they
project those numbers out five or 10
years out and look at the multiple you'd
pay for revenues in year 10. kind of a
dangerous game to play, right? But
that's basically it means that you can
now use price earnings ratios because 10
years from now your company's expected
to make earnings. Two things to
remember. If you do this, you got to do
it for all the companies in your peer
group. You can't just do this for your
company, right? Which is not that messy
because I think Capital IQ gives you
forecasted revenues for your company at
least 5 years out. It's called a forward
multiple. So here's how it'll work.
Let's suppose your company is a small
company right now is an Ebidov minus 100
million but you expected to have Ebidov
500 million 10 years from
now let's say mature companies in your
business traded 10 times
EITA 10 * 500 gives you 5 billion in
year 10 right can I compare that to the
market cap
today the 10 billion is what I expect
this company to be worth 10 years from
now first I have time value of money to
factor in which is the market prices
today. This is 10 years out. So I've got
to discount the 10 billion back. The
other thing I got to factor in is I to
live 10 years to get to year 10. And
during those 10 years, what do my cash
flows look
like? Usually big negative cash flows.
There's a present value effect. And if
there's a failure risk, that's got to be
factored in as well. I see analysts
using forward multiples all the time,
not correcting. They might do the time
value part. They won't correct for
failure risk. They're not correcting for
negative cash flows, which means you're
going to overvalue companies using
forward multiples because you're not
factoring in the noise. In a very early
valuation of Tesla, this was like 10
years ago at a terminal value in my
valuation of 69 billion, which is well
above the market cap at the time. And I
concluded the stock was overvalued then.
And I got pushed back saying, "But you
gave us a terminal value of 69 billion.
that's so much higher than the market
cap today. Why can't I call it
undervalued? So basically I took the 69
billion and essentially stepped it down
with each adjustment. First I said if
you just discount back at the risk-free
rate you lose 2.05 billion. You discount
back at the rest the risk adjusted cost
of capital you drop to 28 billion. You
adjust for the fact that you have
negative cash flow. So by the time I was
done adjusting for all of that, that
forward value became a current value of
8.2 billion. It's a good way of
illustrating how forward numbers kind of
lose steam as you adjust to each of
those factors. So if you have a money
losing company, you can either try what
I did with Amazon and see if you can
find something that explains the
differences or use a forward multiple,
but then remember to try to at least
adjust the failure risk and the other
issues you brought up during the
intrinsic
valuation. So yeah, go ahead M. I saw
that you adjusted for the dilution uh by
new equity issuance because we're not
doing a discounted cash flow valuation,
right? and a discounted cash flow
valuation gets done for you. That's why
we didn't care. When you're doing
pricing, we haven't factored that in.
Right? So here you have to explicitly
adjust for
dilution because if you don't, you're
going to end up so the dilution effect
here is just take the negative cash
flows discounting the back. The
alternative is you can take the value
and divide by the total number of shares
you will have outstanding with the
diluted shares issued. do one or the
other but you have to factor in delusion
explicitly or you'll overvalue the
company
right so ultimately pricing is about
playing by the market's rules it's not
what you think or I think is should
matter it's what the market thinks
should matter so about 10 or 15 years
ago when user and subscriber based
companies kind of took off you know
Facebook and Google and you know it's
transaction based some are advertising
based one of the challenges you face was
people were computing market cap per
user for
companies and the question is what do we
control for then so here's 20 October
2013 was when Twitter went public and I
wanted to price Twitter I done an
intrinsic valuation of Twitter I wanted
to price it so I collected data on other
social media companies that got much of
their value from online advertising
because that's where Twitter got its
value so there's the market cap of these
publicly traded companies. LinkedIn was
a separate company then Microsoft hadn't
bought it then. There's the enterprise
value and then I collected accounting
data to see if any of them would explain
the differences in market cap across
these companies. So I collected revenues
EIDA none of
them gave had much correlation with
market cap until I got to the number of
users. So you can comput enterprise
value per user. So here's what I did. I
computed the correlation between the
market values I got for these companies
and all of these
variables because I could sit there and
say revenues matter, evida matters, but
the market has a very different view of
this. If you look across
uh correlation with number of users is
almost one. You tell me how many users
you have as a company, I can pretty well
predict what your market cap should be.
So, you know how I priced Twitter at 240
million users when it went public. I
multiplied it by roughly $100 per user
which is what I you know if you look at
the previous page 97.41 41. Round it up
to 100. 240 * 100 is 24 billion. I'm
done. This is pricing 101, right? You
know what? That's roughly what it went
public
at is roughly 24 billion. Sometimes we
over complicate pricing. The question we
should ask is what is the market looking
at when it prices companies? And it's
purely datadriven question. It's not
driven by theory. And once you've
identified it, you got your pricing. I
know some of you are valuing young
biotechnology companies and farmer
companies. What do you think the market
pricing I mean obviously it's not based
on current revenues and current
earnings. What what do you think drives
the differences in market pricing across
them? You want to try it? It's whatever
drug they have.
That's basically it. It's total market.
So if you have a drug that can treat
diabetes and it looks promising, you're
going to get a much much higher pricing
than for a disease that only a you know
few thousand or a few hundred people do.
So that's what you'd collect that to
price these companies. You'd have to get
a sense of what the total market is for
the drugs they're trading and maybe
it'll work, maybe it won't. You have to
leave the door open that you could have
a great hypothesis, but the data says
no, it's not working. You got to be
willing to abandon it. But that's what
you start with. If I were somebody
buying the stock, what would I look at?
And then you try to extrapolate from
that to see what drives difference in
pricing across
companies. So we kind of covered a whole
spectrum. You have a followup question.
Nikita, you also use this logic for
something like Uber or Dash, which is
like an That's a good question. You
know, what do you think um right sharing
companies are price based? So now they
have more substance, right? Now they
have revenues and users, you know, but
before they had revenues, obviously you
had to base it on something. You
probably based it on writers or, you
know, sub, you know, people using it.
But I think at some point you got to
move on from that. In fact, even within
that space, you went from users to
active users because investors
discovered you could have hundreds of
millions of users, many of whom never
come on your platform. They're on your
platform, but they never use it. So they
went to active users and they went to
monthly active users because you got
have active us. So you could see even
within the user space things getting I
won't call them more refined more
focused and eventually you got to leave
users behind and have revenues right
that transition has to happen somewhere
because users by themselves know neither
here nor there. So picture
how would you apply that biotech logic
of market size to young biotech
companies that are maybe doing R&D in
the orphan drug space or very very niche
you're buying options there you're not
even buying a business you're buying an
option it's an option but even there
I'll have to find out what you're doing
I mean even basic research is directed
somewhere right if you said look I'm
doing basic research but I have no idea
what disease this will treat I'm not
funding you not now not ever right that
that kind of research should happen at
universities if they get the funding you
know but you know basically research cuz
I need some focus on where the research
is going to attach a number and that's
why even very basic research I'm looking
at where are you going with this
research eventually
yes um if you're pricing based on a lot
of users how do we bring in the pricing
power that the company might have
you use number of users because that
hasn't shown up yet right because each
if you take these companies now I'm no
longer pricing them on number of users
and eventually what happened here was
Facebook started if you look across the
users here Facebook you're paying uh
let's see it's 130 but you also have you
know trip advisor 4946 you know what
you'd have to do is you then have to
bring in things that you think will
explain why people are paying more per
Netflix subscriber than for a Facebook
user it might take the form of Netflix
as a subscription model. So you can
start adding things that explain why you
have differences in per user or per
subscriber prices and bring in this.
It's all data driven. Again, there's no
theory driving it. But the advantage if
you start with an intrinsic value base,
you can at least ask why would I value
user higher in one company than another.
You know what I throw in here? I throw
in the number of minutes people spend on
a platform which is actually in the
public domain. You can see I don't know
who how they know but it's scary that
they do know 57 minutes on Facebook 6
minutes on Twitter already you can start
to explain why a user in one platform is
worth more than another if you have an
advertising
business. So all of these examples I've
given I picked a sector I picked a
multiple and I've tried to explain
whether a company's cheap or expensive
relative to a peer group.
Right? But if you think about it, if can
control for differences in risk and
growth and cash flows, I don't need to
stay focused with a peer group. I can
compare a company to the rest of the
market. I should be able to compare a
utility company to a software company if
I can control differences in cash flows,
growth, and risk. Remember, investors
don't buy sectors. They buy a collection
of cash flows. That's what you're
getting when you buy a
stock. So, here's what I'm going to try
to do. I'm going to try to extend my
comparison to the entire market. In a
sense, you're asking a different pricing
question. You're asking, is Amazon cheap
given how the rest of the market is
priced? And that answer can be different
from is Amazon cheap relative to
other.com
stocks. So here's what I'm going to
start with. I took the entire US equity
market and I've been this regression.
I've been running for 30 years. Have the
regressions going back in time. What's a
compelling variable for
P? It's expected growth, right? net
income in the future divide by net
income. Now I start with a scatter plot.
Why? And and the reason I start with the
scatter plot is I don't want to get my
hopes up too
high if this is the most significant
variable. I am in deep trouble already
when I run the regression. Right? You
don't get this nice neat line where
every point is on the line. Clearly
there's a lot of noise in this process.
This is PE versus growth.
I still ran the regression of PE against
growth rates, payout ratios, and beta.
And you can see why I picked those
three, right? If you go back and look at
what drives PE ratio, those are the
three variables. So, this is not a
kitchen sink regression where my
objective is to get the highest R squ. I
want to see what fundamentals do to
explain difference in P. Let's start
with the R
squ. Am I happy? No, it's ne I'm neither
happy nor unhappy. It is what it is. P
ratios are really difficult to explain
differences across. And so if you use P
ratios, you need to be aware of that.
It's a noisy
multiple. There are the three variables
expected growth, payout, and beta.
First, let's look at the coefficients.
51.92 on growth rate. Every 1% increase
in growth rates for US companies at the
start of 2025 increases my PE ratio by
0.52. So if your company has a growth
rate 10% higher than mine, your PE ratio
should be roughly 5.2 higher than mine.
So that makes sense. Higher P rat payout
ratios feed into a higher PE. Again,
that makes sense. If you for any given
growth rate, you're able to pay out more
of your earnings as
dividends, you should be worth more. And
then I get to a beta and I have a
problem. Do you see what the problem is?
In theory, at least you work out the
intrinsic value equation. As beta goes
up, what should happen to P
ratios? Risk goes up, P should go down,
right? For God's sakes, don't go in and
put a minus there because that'll make
more sense. It is what it is. The data
is saying across US stocks, higher beta
stocks have higher P ratios than lower
beta
stocks. How would he explain that? Makes
no sense, right? Why would
higher? There's a statistical
reason and that requires we remember
things about multiple regression we've
been trying to forget for a very long
time.
Right? First remember when you run this
regressions you're assuming linearity.
That's not the reason for the the wrong
coefficient. But you know you run a
linear regression in today's statistics
packages. If you don't want that
linearity there's a way we can get
around. We'll talk about it but we're
assuming linearity. Second, we're
assuming stationerity. What does that
mean? That things don't keep shifting on
a monthly or because you are running a
cross-sectional regression. And there's
a third requirement when you run a
multiple regression, which is the
independent variables are supposed to be
independent of each
other. It's supposed to be uncorrelated.
Is there a way I can check to see if
they're uncorrelated? Absolutely. I ran
a correlation matrix and you you see
very quickly why that uncorrelated part.
Before I do that though, when you see
any of these when you run these
regressions and you see the t statistic
and the t statistic doesn't hold up,
just take it out of the regression. It's
better to run a clean regression with
with coefficients that matter rather
than push them all. So don't sit there
saying this is supposed to matter, so
I'm going to leave it in there. Right?
But one of the things that I've run into
with these regression that I did not run
into in 2025 is sometimes when you run
the regression you can get a negative
intercept which means the slope of the
line was steep and kind of you're saying
so what if you have a negative intercept
there is a possibility that you get a
predicted number from this regression
that predicted number can be
negative and that's a problem for me why
because PE ratios are not supposed to be
negative there's a fix for this in
Almost every regression package that you
open up, Mini Tab, SPSS, or even in
Excel, it allows you to take the
constant out of the equation. You say,
"Why would I do that?" Here's why you do
that. If you have the intercept be
negative, the easiest way to fix it is
to set the constant to zero. So, it
forces the line through zero. It's a
less good regression in terms of fit
because you forced it through zero, but
you no longer have that problem. The
intercept driving predicted values to
negative numbers. I mean, none of you
will might have to run a market
regression, but it's actually kind of
fun with the data. If you ever have to
try a statistics exercise, take all the
companies, you can download them from
Capital IQ, run the regression, see what
you get as the R squar and the
coefficients.
But here's the thing that showed me that
I had a a pro. So remember the
requirement that your independent
variables be uncorrelated with each
other. When that requirement is
violated, you have what's called
multiolinearity. I remember my
statistics class hearing that and say
who
cares? And then I ran this regression
and said I should have cared
more. Multiple linearity basically means
when you have independent variables in
this case payout growth and beta all of
these numbers that are not on the on the
diagonal should be
zero and if you look at the actual
numbers expected growth is higher for
riskier stocks which makes sense higher
growth stocks have higher betas and
lower payout ratios by indep you're
saying so what if they they correlate
what does a computer see when you run a
regression it sees four columns of data,
right? You might have labeled them, but
it doesn't care what the labels are. It
sees four columns of data. Let's say all
your high growth companies also have
high
betas. You see how the computer's going
to get confused? Beta becomes a proxy
for growth rather than risk. And you get
that positive
coefficient. What should we do about it?
Probably
nothing because the coefficients are
tough to read. But the regression itself
still works as a predictor. You can use
the overall regression. Don't overread
the coefficients because the
coefficients are going to be messed up
by the
multiolinearity. So I'm going to leave
the regression as is recognizing that
the individual coefficients are messy
but that the overall prediction
works. So in a sense that's what all of
quantum investing has become is this is
a very simplistic statistical tool you
know a linear regression with three but
you could make this nonlinear you could
add in other variables you can add
social data in if you can find a way to
classify them to be numerical and that's
become this entire process of quant
investing and active investing is
bringing the data in trying to see if
you can come up with this master
regression across the data that will
tell you what stock should be priced at
because once you get the regression you
can price any stock in the market right
you plug in that stock's beta growth
rate in this case I took a Disney growth
rate of 15% beta 0.90 20% payout ratio
you plug it in you can get a predicted
price earnings ratio for any company
compared to the actual P the actual P at
that time is 40.4 four times earnings.
Your conclusion would be that Disney is
overpriced. But remember the nature of
this regression is you're going to get
half of stocks be underpriced, half be
overpriced. You can put in, you know,
90%, you know, confidence intervals. You
could write, you could be a one person
hedge fund, buy the 10% on each side
that are underpriced or overpriced and
hope they move to the regression line.
That's the allure of quantum investing
is if you can build that master
regression and then pray and hope that
the market moves towards that master
regression, you're effectively making
money on both sides of the
mispricing. One of the things I do have
tracked every year is that coefficient
on
growth. It is 0.52 I think this year.
Let me go back and see where it was.
0.52 which means every 1% growth I'm
paying 0.52. Think of that as the price
for
growth. We have a price for risk as well
that we've been
tracking the equity risk premium. Right?
So let me show you what the two numbers
have done against together over time. So
you go back to 2000 there's the price
for growth. Markets were paying a huge
amount for growth and not charging very
much for risk. That's a 2% equity risk
premium. So if you're a high growth,
high-risisk company, this was nirvana
for you. You were trading at 200 times
earnings. Over time, if you track those
two numbers, they kind of give you the
ups and downs of markets and periods
when markets get scared. The price of
risk shoots up and the price you're
willing to pay for growth drops off.
2008,
2009. Where do we stand in 2025? The
price of risk is high relative to where
it was in 2000. lower than it was a year
or two or three years ago, but the price
you're paying for growth is not
outlandish relative to history. So, it's
a number I track over time because it
might give me an indicator as to when
you're getting this mismatch in the
price of risk and the price of growth
that comes directly out of the
regressions. I'll do one more multiple
kind of talk about a multiple that
doesn't fit the linearity assumption as
me. Remember we talked about peg ratios.
Peg ratios are messy. This graph I've
taken peg ratios and graphed them
against the growth rate because it turns
out growth doesn't disappear. So that's
what the peg ratio looks like. I might
be just seeing things, but doesn't it
look like there's a bit of a almost a
curve to
it? I know this might be just my
imagination like cloud watching. After a
while, you watch clouds, you they can
look not like cloud data, but the actual
clouds, you can make them look like
whatever you want them to look at. So, I
did the natural law. I think this looks
much better from a linearity
assumption. If I have to fit a line, I
have a chance of fitting a a straight
line through this. There's no chance I
could fit through the previous one.
One of the things you can try when you
have a multiple is start with the
scatter plot and if you see it something
that looks like the peg ratio try the
natural log. It actually does amazing
things to make the relationship more
linear. So in the case of peg ratios I
ran the regression with log of growth as
my as my coefficient for growth. So it's
just a natural
log regression terrible R square again
0.5 but that's the nature of PEG ratios
tough to explain.
Beta is this positive coefficient that
you know the multiolinearity is just
sluring you. Payout ratio positive log
of growth is actually negative. Higher
growth companies have lower peg ratios
at least in the
cross-section. PE ratios and PEG ratios
have always had the most trouble trying
to explain the lowest R squares. It
improves when you go to price to book,
EV to sales, EV to advertise back and
forth. But basically when you look
across multiples it tells you some
multiples are easier to explain and use
than other multiples. For better or
worse people are stuck on PE ratios and
they keep using a multiple that by its
very nature is the most difficult
multiple to explain across
companies. So I'll say the next few
pages are just my updated 2025
regression. Start of every year I run
regressions for a bunch of multiples. I
did this is price earnings no across
markets and you can see R squares vary
across markets same three variables in
every market the fundamentals don't
change but very different slopes on the
growth across regions why because if you
want to price your company against the
entire market I don't want you running
the regression from scratch it's too
much work too messy you can use this
regression it'll give you a third number
for your stock an intrinsic value per
share a pricing against the sector which
you'd have you can price it against the
market. Could you get different
conclusions? Absolutely. But you're
because you're asking three different
questions and getting them answered. So
that's PE ratios. I do PEG ratios.
Notice the log of earnings per share.
And if you notice that for Europe, the
payout seem to have dropped out because
the t statistic was not significant. So
if it's not significant, I take it out
of the regression. But I always start
with the same variables in every part.
Right? So browse through the remaining
pages because I think I have PEG ratio,
EV to debit die, EV to invested capital,
EB to sales. So no matter which multiple
use, if you want to price your company
against the market, you can use one of
these
regressions. So let me cut to the bottom
line
on on on the pricing game. You have
choices, right? First, you got to decide
whether you're going to price relative
to enterprise value, equity value, or
firm value. That's going to be
determined largely by what kind of
company you have. If you have a bank,
it's not even a question. Just stay with
equity value. But if you have a firm
with in any other sector, if there are
big differences in leverage, go with an
enterprise value multiple. It's always
safer. What you going to scale it to?
Revenues, earnings, cash flows. Of
course, if the only number you're
positive is revenues, beggars can't be
choosers. You got to use revenues or
revenue
drivers. But if you have earnings, book
value, which one is best? There is no
best multiple as long as you control for
differences on the things you need to
control
for. For in terms of timing, you can use
current numbers, you can use trailing
numbers, you can use forward numbers,
you can use normalized numbers. Just
remember to do it for all of your
companies in the same way. It's
important that you be consistent in that
choice. And if you're a cyclical
company, you might decide to replace the
current numbers with normalized numbers.
oil companies rather than use last
year's numbers. You might use an average
over the last 10. And finally, if you
look at comparables, you have to decide
what your peer group should be. You
might decide to go with a regional peer
group. With US companies, you can get
away with it because you have enough
companies in the US. But if you're doing
Turkish companies, you might have no
choice but to go across Europe or even
global because you will not get enough
companies in your peer group.
So make your choices. There's no right
choice because once you made the choice
just important that you do all your
companies on that and if you start
losing a lot of companies based on your
choice of multiple go back and pick a
different
one pick PE and twothirds of your
companies are gone because of negative
earnings switch do something else which
brings more companies into the
mix. So here are my bottom line
propositions about pricing. None of them
should be surprising at this point.
First in a pricing remember when you
tell me something is cheap or expensive
it has to come with a qualifier which is
what did you compare it to? Telling me
something is cheap or expensive on a
pricing basis is incomplete until I look
at what you compare it to.
Second let's face it there are no
comparable companies. There will always
be differences on cash flows growth and
risk. The question whether you choose to
ignore them or choose to control for
them. I gave you know if you want to use
statistics do so. If you feel
uncomfortable using statistics you still
have to figure out another way of
controlling for differences because
otherwise you're going to be picking
stocks that look cheap but also deserve
to be cheap. Right? So it's a pricing
game and if you do it well that's at the
basis for almost 90% of what happens in
markets right now. It's trading. You're
pricing things. You're hoping it works
out.
I don't I I I'm not attaching a judgment
to pricing. It's just a different
game. Any questions about pricing in
general? Define, describe, analyze,
apply. Right? Define, remember the
consistency principle. Uni, make sure
they're uniformly estimated. Describe is
just look at all the data. Do a
histogram. Get a sense of what's high,
what's low. Don't fall for rules of
thumb. Analyze do that intrinsic value
equation equity multiple for you know
DCF you know dividend discount model for
an equity multiple a free cash for the
firm model for an enterprise value
multiple so you know what variables to
control for and only then apply define
describe analyze apply.
So that's pricing. Let's talk a little
bit about assetbased valuation. Sounds
mysterious, but so far we've been
valuing entire companies,
right? In theory, there is no reason why
we can't value individual assets that
the company owns and add them all up.
It's called assetbased valuation. A lot
of accountants prefer assetbased
valuation because they like balance
sheets. They start with each item. How
much is that worth? How much is that
worth? So here are the scenarios where
you might have to do assetbased
valuation. First is if you're doing a
liquidation, you're not selling the
company, you're selling individual
assets. You got to value the individual
assets, right? The second is if you're
doing fair value accounting and I thank
my stars that I don't do fair value
accounting. You have no choice but to
value individual assets, right? Because
you got to come up with a balance sheet.
And the third is if you're an active
investor or an activist investor who
wants to buy a company and break it up,
you need to do assetbased valuation
because you're selling the pieces off.
So let's put that on the table.
Sometimes you got to value assets.
You're not valuing the
company. There are three ways in which
you can value the assets of a company.
And if this sounds familiar, it should.
First is you can take each asset, do an
intrinsic valuation of the asset based
on its cash flows, growth, and risk. The
second is you can price every asset
based on what other assets like it
people are paying and the third is if
there's some optionality you can try to
apply it there but the third is you can
trust accountants and use the book value
would not be my choice but a lot of some
of the parts valuation people do take
accounting numbers and use it as the
estimate of what the asset is worth so
intrinsic and that's why when I when I
did my initial class I didn't put
assetbased valuation as a different
approach approach to valuation because
it's just applying one of these
approaches to attach a number to an
asset. So, let's talk about when
assetbased valuation is going to be
easiest to do and when it's going to be
messy. If I gave you a company that had
seven real estate properties on which
it's collecting rental
income, assetbased valuation is slam
dunk, right? You can take each building,
value it separately because they're
separable. If I ask you to do an
assetbased valuation of Disney, it's
going to be a nightmare. Why is
that? Even if I break Disney down into
theme park revenues, you know,
broadcasting, movie revenues, why is it
going to be difficult to value each
piece? Yes, because they rely on each
other because there's a codependence,
right? When your movies do well, more
people come to your theme park. So when
you have a business where there are
cross business synergies, it's going to
be much much more difficult to do asset
based valuation. Right? Second, it's
nice if you have standalone earnings
from each
asset, which real estate properties
obviously fit, but when you talk about
multi-business companies, an accountant
might estimate earnings by division, but
often it's based on
allocating expenses rather than having
direct expenses.
And third, it is nice to have an active
market for similar assets. In other
words, if I want to value theme parks
separately, I want publicly traded theme
park companies I can use to be able to
price those
assets. So already you can see if I gave
you the 50 largest market cap companies
in the US, some are going to be easier
to value in an assetbased basis and
others are more difficult.
So let's look at the three ways in which
you see asset based valuation play out.
First is liquidation valuation where
you're trying to get get a sense of what
will I get if I liquidated the company.
It's true I can do an intrinsic
valuation but let's face it when I'm
doing a liquidation valuation it should
really be liquidation pricing right
because you have to sell it today at
whatever people are willing to pay for
it. And if you have assets that are
again separable and traded, you can do
the pricing, add the pricing up and say
this. The one thing though is if you're
in a hurry to
liquidate, might you have to settle for
a discount?
Absolutely. So if you're doing a
liquidation valuation, you can price
each individual asset. You might attach
a discount at the end saying I need to
get the money in the next 3
months. Who's doing Weight Watchers?
Somebody in the class is doing Weight
Watchers. The company. No, I'm not
saying Weight Watchers isn't losing
weight. Now, I'm not trying to pick on
you know, Weight Watch as a company is
on the verge of bankruptcy, right? And I
read this morning that people that
bankers are trying to put a liquidation
value. I'm not even sure what you'd be
liquidating and how you'd price it,
right? Because what do you have as an
asset as Weight Watchers? You can have
the name. I don't think anybody wants
that name because it's got this taint to
it now in today's day and age. You don't
wait watches.
No, you have the list of people who are
your, you know, there some loyal people
on there. You could probably
set putting a liquidation pricing on
this is going to be really difficult to
do, but people are going to
try. The second is accounting valuation.
I might have told you the story about 20
years ago when the panel that was
writing the fair value accounting
rules came to New York and they were
meeting and they said can you come in
and talk to us and I said are you sure
you got the right guy you know what I
think about accounting right they said
no no we'd like to talk about fair value
accounting and they said okay they can
you send me what you're planning to do
and they sent me this this FAZ 157 which
was the rule that was going to govern
fair value accounting And I read through
the rule and here's what I saw. I saw
mention of a market participant. That
basically the number you should put on
an asset is what a market participant
would pay for that asset in an
armslength
transaction. So I sent an email saying
should you be calling this fair value
accounting or should you be calling it
fair price accounting? They said what's
the difference? And I said that's the
problem. You don't know the difference
cuz this is a pricing mission. You know,
much of the frustration in fair value
accounting is accountants are given a
pricing mission, but then what are they
required to turn in to back up that
pricing? A discounted cash flow
valuation. Of course, it's not going to
work. You're going to stretch what
you're allowed to do in DCF. So when you
look at fair price fair value accounting
you really have a pricing mission which
means if you're going to put numbers and
assets in fair value accounting what
should you be using multiples and
comparables doing pricing right it'll
save you think of the frustration it'll
save you in addition to coming up with
numbers that actually make sense given
the mission you're trying to do. Fair
value accounting has nothing to do with
value. It's got everything to do with
price. And the sooner we accept that,
the healthier the discussion about fair
value accounting will get. So that's
liquidation valuing valuation, fair
value accounting. Let's talk about the
only part of assetbased valuation that
I'm interested in which is investing in
a way you can act on this. It's called
sum of the parts
valuation where you value the individual
parts of a company and you add up those
parts. They're higher than the market
cap of the company today. You argue the
company's undervalued. you're a passive
investor and then you hope and pray that
the market comes to that recognition and
moves the
price. The other is if you're an
activist investor who plans to take over
the company and break it up there, you
actually act on your sum of the pots
valuation cuz you said this company is
worth 30% less than the sum of its
parts. I'm going to go buy it in the
market and then we sell off the
pots. I'm not going to ask you to do
this, but some of you are valuing
multi-business companies, right? Could
you value your company as the sum of the
parts? What would you need? Let's say
you're in three different business. What
did you need, Michael? Well, you need uh
revenue breakdown for each segment. You
need margin and then um you need cost of
capital, depreciation, working capital.
In other words, you almost need full
financial statements, right? And most of
the time you're not going to have it.
The biggest challenge with doing some of
the parts valuation is information. The
technique is the same, right? If I had
full financials for every one of the
Disney divisions, I could
try. But even with full financials, the
problem is these expenses you see in the
financials are often allocated expenses,
right? It's not like these. So I'm going
to give you an example of a company
where I was able to do a sum of the
parts valuation. You're going to see
what allowed me to do it. It's a company
called United Technologies. I used to
call it the poor person's G. Now it's
become the rich person's GE because it's
actually better than G as a company. But
at that time GE was the star top of the
market cap heed technologies was a
conglomerate. And here are the business
it was in carrier which is a
refrigeration systems business. Prattton
Whitney defense business. Otis which is
elevators in most buildings. So it's
construction business. UTC fire and
security obviously security business
Hamilton Sunstrren which is
manufacturing and Sakorski which is
aircraft six very distinct businesses
but here's where United Technologies
made life easy for me they actually
broke down revenues abid I mean
basically the numbers you wouldn't
expect to see on a divisional basis most
companies who break down revenues about
a third of companies who break down
operating income very few do it at the
level that United Tech technologies do.
So I'm going to do two things. First,
I'm going to try to do an intrinsic
valuation of each of these businesses.
And second, I'm going to try to price
each of these businesses. Let's start
with the intrinsic valuation. To do the
intrinsic valuation, oh, first before I
do that, let's do the the back of the
envelope process that analysts go
through when they claim that a company's
cheap on a sum of the parts basis.
They're not doing valuation. They're not
even doing good pricing. What they do is
they take the median multiples at which
companies in each of these sectors trade
at apply to the so the EIDA that I got
from this page they apply the E. So in
this case I picked EV to Ebita. I could
have picked a different multiple you
multiply the EIDA for each division by
the median multiple and you come up with
a shoulder price of each business. You
add them up. That's a sum of the parts
pricing of the company. What are the
flaws with this approach? What am I What
am I implicitly assuming? By now, you
know, enough pricing to to kind of pick
this
apart. What What am I missing when I do
this? Yes, ma'am. They're assuming that
it's an average business by taking that
basically each of these businesses in
United Technologies resembles the
average company in the peer group.
Right? That's the first problem. Second
is there is there are expenses that they
don't have in any of these businesses
like a GNA expense that's separate.
They're completely ignoring it. It's
almost like they assume that it'll go
away if you break this company up and
sell it off in
pieces. But this is basically when
analysts say some of the parts
valuation, this is all they've done.
Applied a median pricing multiple to
Ebida revenues. they prefer to stick
with Ebidar revenues because it's see
you know it's you at least those numbers
tend to be positive and add them all up
right so I'm going to try to do pricing
right before we do an intrinsic
valuation what does pricing right
require you to do first you can have a
different multiple for each group
depending on which works best so I
actually ran regressions with each of
the multiples picked the highest R
squared so these were the regression the
multiples that emerged as the multiples
I could explain the best within each
sector and then I plugged in for for
each of the businesses what know United
Technologies numbers look like for each
division return on capital growth rate
so I'm getting a predicted multiple for
each division based on the pure group
and based on the numbers that United
Technology was delivering in each
business. So think of this as a slightly
more sophisticated version of pricing.
I'm still pricing but I'm pricing using
different multiples and using the
differences between United Technologies
divisions and the rest of your group.
What I got as the sum of the pricing was
about 74.23 billion. Why is it higher?
Because it turns out that United
Technologies divisions are more
profitable, higher growth than the pure
group and that shows up as a higher
pricing. Still, I haven't brought in the
GNA but that's think of that as a better
pricing. So you got the median multiple
pricing, you got this adjusted
pricing. I put out the intrinsic
valuation for the last step because it's
messy, right? To do an intrinsic
valuation of each business, what do I
need? I need to estimate cash flows
grow. In other words, if I had a FCF
simple GZU model, I'd have six or five
different FCF simple Ginsu models where
I have a different story for each
business, different revenue growth,
different margins, different
reinvestment.
So first thing I did was I computed a
cost of capital for each of the five
businesses. You know why I'm able to do
this? Because I don't use a regression
beta, right? If I use a regression beta,
this process breaks down because I use a
bottom up beta. I stayed with the bottom
up beta for each business, different
cost of different betas, different cost
of equity. And the debt ratio, I
cheated. I left the debt ratio at the
company's debt ratio because they're all
pretty capital intensive business. It's
not like you know I expected one
business to be high debt ratio and the
other low debt ratio. You can see the
difference in cost of capital. Fire and
security has the lowest cost to capital
and secori has the highest cost to
capital. So I've got my cost of capital
by business. To get the growth rate I
did use sustainable growth. Why? Because
I was
lazy. I estimated a reinvestment rate
for each business and a return on cap
for each business. Already you can see
there are good and bad businesses in the
mix, right?
and security might be their their safest
business, but it's also their lowest
return on capital
business. So, if you take the return
capital times the reinvestment rate,
you're going to get the growth rate for
each of these companies. So, I've got a
different cost of cap for each business,
a return on capital and reinvestment
rate for each business because I had
that raw data given to me broken
down. And I did six different discarded
cash flow models, you know, for each
business separately. One one of them
security I treated as a mature business
because its growth rate was already less
than the risk-free rate. The others I
gave a 5year growth period. None of them
are really really high growth and then I
brought them to stable growth. So
essentially all I'm doing differently
are instead of valuing one company with
one discounted cash flow model, I'm
valuing six different businesses.
think it's a real
mess. You built the conglomerate. You
got to be ready to value the pieces. And
there are bonuses you get when you break
the business down because you can ask
which of these businesses do I want to
grow more and which one should I shrink?
The answer should really come from
looking at the return on capital by the
different
businesses. Here's the bottom line. I
did an intrinsic valuation of each
business. Added them all up. There's my
intrinsic value for the company. You
remember what the sophisticated pricing
was? It was like 74 billion. My
intrinsic valuation is higher because it
captures some of the nuances in the cash
flows that I could not catch in my
pricing. So I've got a blunt tool
pricing. I've got a sophisticated
pricing. I've got an intrinsic value.
But in doing all of this, there's one
number that I've kind of ignored which I
need to bring in. The company had about
$48 million in unallocated GNA expense.
They said reported separately. I'm not
going to assume it goes away. I'm not
that cynical about GNA. I'm assuming
these are centralized expenses that
these six companies
share. We they're unable to allocate it
because it's, you know, one accounting
team, one inventory team, whatever it
is. But those costs I assumed would
continue in perpetuity. And I computed
the present value of those GNA costs. 48
million growing at 3% which is my stable
growth rate. That's a 4.6 billion drain
on value because that GNA cost is going
to reduce my value. So if I did my
intrinsic valuation right, I take the
80.25 subtract out the
4587. My DCF value for the sum of the
parts is 75.6 billion.
My relative valuation done right is 74
billion. If I did just the company DCF
as an aggregated DCF, I got 71 billion.
The stock was actually trading at 52
billion. And I think there people talk
about conglomerate discounts.
Now, this is rather than apply a
discount to your DCF, you do your DCF
and then you look at the pricing and you
say, "Look, is there that much
inefficiency built in here that I'm
willing to take a 33% rate down on the
value?" I know different points in time
companies like Sony have been targeted
by activist saying you're worth more as
a sum of the parts. I wouldn't take that
further than I can take it because most
of it is based on that very blunt level
pricing of these companies. So if you
see a multi- business company that you
think would be more interesting broken
up the best way to kind of address that
is to actually do what I was able to do
with United Technology but your biggest
impediment might be the lack of
information. Yes. So some of the
conglomerates they have these company
transactions like for example the
aircraft with such defendants how do you
treat those intersection transaction see
the problem is anytime you're so you're
talking about within division revenues
one company's revenues will be another
company's expenses right so one
company's income will be raised another
so it'll it'll all be in the numbers
already so when you have inter segment
revenues you don't even have to bring
them in because they're being counted in
one business as revenues in another. So
that's moreformational for you to know
that there's this
intersection. The times that can get you
into trouble is though those are not
from arms length transactions. So if
it's a family group company and you're
selling stuff too cheap to another
another part of the company, then you
can get a reallocation of value. So the
effect will be in you'll value one
business too much and another too little
if those prices are not fair prices. So
I would just ignore it when you do this.
The problem though is watch out for the
GNA expense that hasn't been allocated
anywhere else because that's not intra
company. It's just extra expenses that
somebody has to
bear. Any any questions about assetbased
valuation? So 2018 I tried to do this
for G and it was a nightmare. By 2018 G
was well past its glory days. So, I took
the the took them down. He's saying,
"Why are the different colors?" I know
they're really ugly colors. The green
are the businesses where they were
earning a return on capital higher than
the cost of
capital. The yellow were the ones where,
you know, you're pretty close. No. And
the two pink are the businesses where
they really should get out of the
business basically. So, you know, it's a
it's it's a kind of mix. It's a mess
when you look at the numbers. So I
actually did a you know intrinsic
valuation of each of the parts and here
was the challenge. I got a value for the
business of 204 billion but that was
after I looked at the GE capital which
had a value of 27 billion but carried
debt of 85 billion. So the net effect of
G capital was a -48
billion or minus yeah -48 billion right
2785 yeah 5 no 58 billion - 58 billion
drain on
value you think why they why did they
just shut down G capital Capital was
draining the value by 58
billion because it was mixed up with all
the other businesses the G aviation
almost every contract was underwritten
by G Capital. G Capital became this
albatross. G could have been, you know,
wound up and sold for a lot more 10
years earlier than it was, but G capital
has made it almost impossible to do
until they got really desperate. Okay,
so here you can see the bulk of the
value and there are good businesses,
average businesses, bad business in the
mix. And that's the nature of
conglomerates. You're going to get a mix
of businesses, some good, some bad. And
if you throw a capital arm in there,
then it becomes really difficult to
disentangle these
businesses and break them up into
pieces. Now, G eventually did it, but it
took them a long time to get
there. I I did also try pricing the
part. Same effect. Gap was still a
drain. But here I looked at the pure
group EV tab. It does very blunt pricing
because it g the kind of information at
the divisional level that would allow me
to do a better pricing. Again, so when
you do some of the parts, so somebody
says sum of the parts, ask them do you
want a sum of the parts valuation or a
sum of the parts pricing? If it's a sum
of the parts valuation, then you have a
lot of work to do, right? Each part has
to be valued separately, its own cash
flows, its own growth, its own risk. If
it's a sum of the parts pricing, it's a
little easier, but you still have to go
to pure groups, pick the right multiple
within each and you can have different
multiples for different businesses and
ultimately add them up. Yes, Michael. I
know you value Tesla a lot. Do you apply
some of the parts for It's tough in
Tesla to separate them out, right? I
mean, are you talking about the robotics
and automated driving as separate parts
because they're not even existent right
now. It'll all be in the future, right?
I think of them more as options than as
businesses right now. Neither is a
standalone business. Neither is even a
business yet. We don't even know what
the real business is. At some point in
time, if they become businesses, would
you do something? Absolutely. It would
be all I think Nvidia effectively I did
some of the parts right. I did the AI
Nvidia and the rest of Nvidia
separately. And there I had to make some
draw some lines in the sand myself
because Nvidia didn't break down some
expenses into AI chip expense then just
do R&D right it's collective R&D so if
the information is not there you're
often drawing lines yourself and then
you wonder whether you know is it worth
it even doing it and that's why most of
the time I value the entire company we
talk about some of the pots can you
value Coca-Cola as the sum of its
geographical
parts yeah you can value the Asian Ian
division separately. You know why this
might be worth doing right now if this
trade war thing reaches its natural
climax and basically companies are not
able to run division cuz remember until
the 80s all multinationals used to have
subsidiaries that were standalone
subsidiaries in most countries. Nestle
had a Nestle India that traded
separately as a company had its own
board of directors. It's an incredibly
frictional system, right? Because now
decision, but it allowed them to
separate companies in different parts of
the world and have this plausible denial
verdict. Coca-Cola US is only in the US
and all these other businesses, but we
don't technically own them. We have an
ownership state. Hopefully, we don't go
back to those days because, as I said,
it's a very inefficient way to run a
multinational.
But if that happens then you might have
to start thinking about geographical
mixes of each of these geographies
having a different value and you own 60%
of the Indian subsidiary 40% of the the
thigh subsidiary and add them all up at
the end make it a nightmare to actually
value companies to do it.
I'm going to set up private company
valuation because I know we kind of roam
through a lot of pricing today. Now
first I mean let's let's set the table.
The process of valuing a private
business is really no different from the
process of valuing a public company. You
got to make a choice. Do you want to
value the entire business or do you want
to value? If that sounds familiar,
that's how we start public companies.
But there are two issues with private
businesses that'll make valuing private
businesses different and potentially
more difficult. The first is the absence
of a market value for equity. You know
what they say, you don't know what what
you're missing until you actually miss
it. In public companies, we take it for
a given that you have market value
market value of equity. You have no
market value of equity. You'll see where
in valuation that's going to come into
play.
Second, at least in smaller private
businesses, the financial statements
might not follow IFRS or GAP, which
means you have a little bit of gaps to
fill in on your own. So, let's start
with the market value question. Why does
it matter that you have no market value
of equity? First, we use market values
as inputs in valuation, right? Where
when we do costic capital, what are the
weights supposed to be on equity and
debt? Market value of equity, market
value of debt. we miss it. Second,
market value. Once you're done valuing
the company, what do you compare it to?
You compare it to the market value. And
if you have a company that's not
publicly traded, you're going to come up
with an intrinsic valuation of your
company, a pricing for your company, but
you have nothing. You're saying, "So
what?" And you did your intrinsic
valuation. You know the signal that you
done something horribly wrong usually
was when you got your intrinsic value,
you got $2 per share and the stock was
trading at $2,000 per share. You know,
markets make mistakes, but this is not
likely to be a mistake, right? Probably
a mistake on your part in terms of units
somewhere. It's nice to have a market
price to compare to because then if
you've really screwed up, it'll give you
an
indication. And we didn't use this, but
a lot of risk based measures are market
price based, right? If you run a beta, a
regression beta, you need past prices to
get
there. So that's the first challenge. No
market price. It's going to leave you
feeling a little
unmorted. Second, on the cash flow
question, four basic problems. First is
many private businesses have not been
around as long as publicly traded
companies. It's not always true. In
fact, the oldest business in the world
was this um Japanese shrine, you know,
repair called Goi. It was 1500 years old
when it shut down. So some private
business been around a long time and I
don't know whether the MBAs still do it
but until a few years ago they used to
have these auctions where they used to
auction off what professors would what
do professors offer except a service. So
I offered to value somebody's company
for them. They won the auction. So
somebody wins the auction pays $2,000.
And I'm laughing paid $2,000 you know
small private business. The guy shows up
with the stack of papers which is like a
thousand pages thick and I said, "Who am
I valuing?" He said, "We make rum." I
said, "Okay, you know, where are you
located?" He said,
"Miami." He said, "By any chance is your
company's named Bardi." Turned out that
it was a Bardi guy who was a nephew or
niece, part of the family was here. So,
privately owned business, 300 years of
history, right? But most of the time
with public with private companies, you
have less history. Second, you do have
differences in accounting standards
across private businesses, especially
small private businesses that can be
wider than differences in public
companies. I still remember somebody in
this class about 10 years ago who
decided to value a mother's flower
shop as her project. She said, "Can I go
ahead?" 6 weeks in, she comes in my
office. I have to change companies. I
said, "What? you had a fight with your
mom or something. She said, "I went to
my mom and asked her for her
financials." And she took me into this
back room where every wall was covered
with post-it notes. I said, "Mom, what
is this?" She pointed to one wall and
said, "That's my revenue wall. Every
time I sell something, I put a post-it
note there. There's my expense wall."
Right? I don't think post-it note
accounting is part of IFRS or GAP. But
if you're a small private business, you
have a flower shop to run. Where's the
time to keep accounting books?
Right? She actually ended up batting the
flower shop in spite of the post-it
notes. The third, and this is not
exclusive to private businesses, but
small private businesses, the line
between the personal and the business
becomes a very gray one, right? There's
a company
car that every evening seems to
disappear around 3:00 when school lets
out.
picking up the owner's
kids and you have to draw the line. This
is how much and this you're not the tax
guy trying to figure out how much of
this is actually an operating
expense. And finally, and this is a
critical one. Many privately owned
businesses, the owner does not charge
himself or herself a salary. And this
can become an issue. You see why? Even
if the income statement is well done, it
follows accounting standards and the
owner does not charge themselves a
salary. What you're seeing reported as
income is really not the income of the
business. I mean on on Shark Tank, this
is always the funniest part of Shark
Tank, right? We made $50,000 last year.
There'd be four people up front saying,
"Did you pay yourself a salary?" No. So
basically, each of you worked for
$12,500 last year as your salary. But
because as an owner you say why would I
pay myself a salary because I get
whatever's left over. So we have to talk
about how to impute that expense in
before you value the private business.
Otherwise you're going to overvalue the
private
business. None of them are
insurmountable problems but they can
make private company valuation messier.
So here's the last thing and we'll we'll
end with this. If anybody ever asks you
to value a private company, let's
remember about 20 years ago, sitting in
my office, this woman barges in, opens
the door, walks in as if it's her
office. She said, "I heard you teach
valuation." I said, "I teach corporate
strategy." I was trying to escape
whatever she was going to ask me. She
said, "No, no, I know you teach
valuation." I said, "Okay." She said,
"Can you help me value my my business?"
And I said,
"Why?" She said, "What do you mean why?"
I said, "Why do you want to know value?
Is it because you're
curious?" Sometimes you own a business.
Is it because you're getting
divorced and you have to pay half of
this value to your spouse? Is it because
the tax guy is after you and you want a
number? So, you have to pay 30% of that
number or is it for a transaction? She
said, "Will that matter?" I said,
"Absolutely. If you're getting divorced,
you probably want a number close to zero
and I might not be able to give it to
you. Tax guy similarly want a loan
number. Motive matters in private
company
valuation and the sooner we accept that
the healthier the discussion
becomes. She finally got around and she
said oh for a transaction and I said to
whom? She said you have a lot of
questions. I said I need to know that as
well. You say what do you mean to whom?
I said, "Is it to an
individual? Is it to another company? Is
it to a private equity investor?"
Because the number I'm going to give you
is going to be different. Already you
can see why AI is going to have a
tougher time with good private company
valuation than public company valuation
because you almost have to gauge what
your what your setup is before you can
attach a value. So on Wednesday when we
come back, here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to take a restaurant owned by
an individual and value it for sale to
another individual. And then I'm going
to ask a question, will the number have
been different if I value to a company
or to a private equity investor? And
we're going to see vast divergences in
value based on who the potential buyer
is. So I would see you on Wednesday. No.
And remember the quizzes next Monday. I
sent out the review session and the past
quizzes. Did you get that last? Yes.
It works.
reaches the